you know what's so funny I was like wait
my headphones and I'm like nope don't
eat them I don't know what about the
headphones makes you feel like a
podcaster and podcasty yeah no of course
[Music]
welcome back to the Drew's News podcast
where we're giving you all the fun
quirky inspiring and yes informative
stories well that exists in the world
and this week I have such a fun co-pilot
who is the queen of tick tock and
SiriusXM Radio I was lucky enough to be
on the first show I called them and
surprised you it's the incredible things
she's here
thank you so much for having me back did
you really not know I was gonna call in
no I had no idea and I didn't even
recognize your voice I was trying to say
so present in the moment and then I
realized it was you and I felt very calm
and comforted and it set me off on a
great course for my first show so thank
you I'm so glad that's great I love the
advice you give to people it's so
calming and rational and sort of like
how to ex
extract the drama yeah out of things and
I feel like that is something that even
when we don't realize we're feeding off
a vet or we think we don't want to feed
off of it somehow we're still nibbling
away yeah I think I think that I'm all
about just making things easier on
ourselves and sometimes all we have to
do to make something easier is just
label it or acknowledge it okay that's
my ego okay that's a little jealousy
going on and that just de-escalates the
situation and makes you remember I'm
just human I'm just reacting to this
situation I know my friend Lisa uh
Pressman who has Dr Elisa Pressman who
has a podcast uh and a whole sort of you
know franchise called raising good
humans and she says this and it applies
to children but she purposefully named
it raising good humans so that it would
be applicable to adults as well and she
says all feelings are valid all
behaviors are not I love that isn't that
so good I love that so much yeah yeah
it's just it's just about acknowledging
your feelings sometimes and if they're
not you know they're valid but you don't
always have to let them overpower you
yes Tings why don't we get into some
stories I love your thoughts and
opinions on things the number one story
uh Pete Davidson removed his Kim
Kardashian inspired tattoo he was
spotted on a movie set recently with a
bandage on his neck right where his in
quotations my girl is a lawyer Inc
resided what are your thoughts about
tattoo removal being spontaneous and
putting a tattoo on you know early
there's sort of a legendary myth about
this you know what are your what is what
does tinks think I well you know I have
some personal experience I have I have a
new boyfriend and he got my initials on
his arm wait what and what was your
response um well I I mean I think
initially I was I know I'm really
flattered it's it's flattering it's
exciting but it's early I mean we're
like we're like seven weeks in so whoa
yeah so it's a little bit early but I
I'm I'm so thankful to Pete for
reminding us that tattoo removal is an
option should we get to that point not
that I not that I'm putting that out
there but I you know it's it's an option
which is good nothing is permanent apart
from taxes by the way it's so true even
my ten-year-old daughter Olive
um I said something about a tattoo and
she said you know well you could just
always have it removed and I said no
that's not how tattoos work that's the
irony of a tattoo it's permanent and
forever and she goes no people have
tattoos removed all the time smart and
smart I think this generation
um because remember when like Johnny
Depp got Winona Forever yeah and then
you changed it to like wino yeah yeah
um it was such Hollywood I mean I know
we're obsessed they could not stop
talking about it yeah and I feel like
for a Pete it's sort of the opposite
like it doesn't even matter anymore
casual like oh he wanted to convey his
love yeah for Kim Kardashian they've
since separated he's moving on and
changing things up a little bit like
nothing about this seems taboo or
shocking the way it was with Johnny Depp
back in the decades ago I know I agree
and I think it's just because everything
feels a little bit less like rock and
roll these days like everything feels a
little bit more planned out like when
Johnny Depp did it there was no social
media he wasn't taking an Instagram of
Winona Forever and putting it on his
Instagram like he didn't think it was
going to be out there in the way that it
was whereas I think now we do things a
lot for Instagram for social media for
tick tock for that so not saying it all
that's why Pete did it very happy for
him and his choice either way but I just
think that we're more
um kind of socially driven in in terms
of what we do I I don't know Pete
Davidson at all
um I don't even know if I've been around
him and I feel like I would remember
because he's a very Dynamic person
I'm making a wild guess here he seems
like someone who really knows how to let
himself fall in love a hundred percent
cosign on that idea yes he I think he I
think he like likes it like I think he
really and I and I admire that me too
much I I'm kind of like that too where
I'm like let's go for it like I I live
to fall in love I don't even mind about
the Heartbreak it's fine I'll take the
good with the bad and he goes for it I
know and by the way every woman that has
been with him Kate Beckinsale Kim
Kardashian they all talk about how
wonderful he is I know there's not a bad
word about him on the street and I know
a few people who have worked with him
and they're like no he is the greatest
he seems like the nicest guy of all the
women that he's been with talk about how
kind he is yes which is like the best
adjective to describe a man is kind and
he's just a sweetie and I think he's
like he got the tattoo they broke up no
big deal he had a good experience I'm
actually surprised that he removed it me
too because it's covered also head to
toe into and like again never been
around him he seems amazing but he seems
like the type of guy who would be like
you know what that was a chapter in my
life and this is a reminder of it and
that's happy and you know I'm surprised
but maybe you know maybe it's just an
aesthetic decision maybe it like you
know maybe it was too hard for him to
look at it it was making him sad yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh Pete Davidson wherever you are out
there
you don't even know this podcast is
happening right now maybe you know tanks
but we just I think women celebrate and
Champion a guy who is not afraid to love
and fall yeah and express it and show it
and everyone who knows him seems to
speak nothing but his Praises so
here here Pete David said okay our next
topic Venus Williams recently said that
she's working on her dating life by
changing herself she told glamor UK I
have had a single life for a long time
and I think it's really easy to get
stuck in a single life and sometimes at
least for me harder to get out of it it
makes you think about yourself and what
you want and how to behave it's
definitely a lot of self-thought and
that's what goes into it thoughts yeah I
I love that first of all I was with
Venus last week no actually no you
weren't yeah how crazy she gave me a
little tennis lesson it was an event and
um it was wild so um she's the coolest
most magnanimous person that like I've
ever met like just so nice like didn't
have to be that kind to everybody and
was just like no you hold the tennis
racket like this tanks and I was like
okay whatever so that's first thing
second thing I love of this strategy
this is something that I always tell my
community because I think it really
starts with you it starts with you and
you have to be in love with yourself
sounds so cheesy eye roll whatever
before you can invite someone to love
you and you know if she's feeling like
she was stuck in a single rut which I
totally also understand because I'm like
the middle of the bed person like don't
want to share stuck in my ways whatever
whatever if she felt like she needed to
do some self work before she can attach
herself to someone that's the most
beautiful unbelievable thing I think
it's a great strategy I was one of those
people I I didn't eye roll when people
said you gotta love yourself in order to
love others I wanted to scream like the
rim on fire and tear everything apart I
was so irritated and angry with people
when they said well you can't love
others unless unless you love yourself
I'm like
just stop it
self-indulgent you know I can't even
listen to you right now I am the if
everyone is happy then I am happy right
that's when I'm calm and for the first
time in my life at 47 I've spent seven
years single and I get it now yeah I
have never been in
a relationship with myself I've never
put myself first I've never given enough
time to be with myself to get to know
myself in this way yeah
um and I maybe that's not a younger
Journey right you know yeah
um I I can't believe how stubborn I was
and I I wish I wasn't I I don't know if
you know I would have been a different
person and I can't turn back time so I
don't want to be disgruntled about my
past that I can't change but now is when
I'm like oh my God it's not nice guys
finish last it's nice guys should finish
first yeah why didn't I take more time
to get to know myself yeah love myself
understand what I needed more
importantly what I didn't need right I
think the best thing that's come out of
being single is not what I need is now
knowing what I don't need yeah and I did
not know these things when I was younger
yeah I really didn't everyone has their
own Journey maybe you weren't right you
were doing other things you weren't
ready to have this experience with
yourself and now and now you are and
everybody has their own time in their
life where they take a couple years and
they're like I'm gonna fall in love with
myself and sometimes it's not even
planned it's on accident you look up and
you like you're saying now and think wow
I've had this time in this space to
really get to know myself think about
what I like think about what I don't
like and more importantly what you
deserve and what you know knowing you're
worth and dating and what you want to
call into your life and now
you're golden I really enjoyed
imprinting on people I really enjoyed
like 50 percenting myself and then
adapting the other person's 50 like two
halves make a whole yeah one love I
couldn't feel more differently now I'm
like oh God two individuals yeah a love
that may meet somewhere but needs to go
back to its own Corners yeah and now
what I found fascinating about what
Venus said is that she said I feel stuck
in being single and I guess some advice
tanks like I do feel a little now almost
that I've over compensated and now I am
too happy being single how do I or a
Venus or people who have dared to have a
relationship with themselves for a long
period of Time how do you put the toe in
the water how do you get out of that how
do you open yourself up again n again
now from this new place of self-worth
yeah it's an interesting question and I
think I've been there too I I really I
really get stuck in being single because
I love it and I know that's weird to say
but I really enjoy being single I can
make myself happy I like my job I like
my friends but I think it's just
honestly keeping an open heart and not
not even looking for it again and I'm
speaking all in cliches today but just
being open to the possibility of meeting
someone and just just being open because
I think you'll find now coming from this
new place after you've done all this
work on yourself things might feel
different and more exciting but all you
have to do is just stay open another
thing that is really kind of I'm just
having this moment right now talking to
this revelation of like we will take so
little we will accept
less we will take the crumbs and the
morsels and make a meal out of it when
it comes to what someone will give you
and the lack thereof and we'll just eat
it up and then if somebody comes with an
abundant dish and all of this
availability it's like we literally go
oh God what's that that's too much
what's wrong with him or them or her or
like and then what's wrong with me that
I can't accept that that has been a
really interesting thing that I could
sort of be starving and convince myself
I was full and if someone comes at me
with fullness I feel like I'm not hungry
right and that is crazy it's crazy it's
crazy that's it's a lot of young dating
life that we have to kind of uncondition
ourselves because it's so true I don't
know why we get in this pattern where
when someone comes with an open heart
and open arm and it's like hey I have
like all these things to give you you're
like whoa I know like whoa like I've
been especially if you're in the zone of
what you are and where I kind of like
live a lot of the time which is like I
can take care of myself I'm good I'm
good and then someone's like you're
awesome like let me just give you all
these things you're like whoa like why
do you why do you want to give them to
me like why are you being so open with
you know but that's what I mean when I
say keep an open mind and open heart
because it's just it's nice to be wanted
and it's nice to to have someone be kind
to you and to just show you love and
once you get over that initial like ick
or whatever it can be really beautiful
so the hope is that all of the self work
and all of the really loving yourself
if you just push through then that will
click in and you'll say this is actually
what I deserve is someone with a full
dish I think you also when you're hungry
and you're trying to feed yourself and
that other person is really there you're
constantly working and doing so much and
maybe the idea is to stop trying so hard
and allow things to flow a little bit
more
and you know just I think open heart
open mind also means a little acceptance
yeah a little calmness a little
um not overreacting or over compensating
maybe like seeing what happened yeah
just kind of like what I call a will see
mentality like you know like because I
think we kind of as humans we always
want to be like okay well this is this
and this that but yeah no okay you meet
someone they're kind of interesting
we'll see
and that's exciting it's like a little
smirk it's the emotional equivalent of a
little like okay we'll see we'll see
mentality trust me it's a really good
thing tinksy I like it all right we'll
be right back after this break to answer
the burning questions you submitted four
tanks I can't wait to hear this we'll be
right back
all right and we're back our next story
relationship therapist Emily Jamia
posted on Tick Tock the five key things
that every couple should avoid if they
want their romance to last she suggested
that couples wait at least a year to get
married always prioritize sex and
continue to have date nights years down
the line she also advised against
schlepping around in sweatpants all day
every day and not following outdated
rules like a man has to be the first one
to make a move those are five very
strong points of view tinks thoughts I I
agree with them I think that's right I
think apart from maybe the sweatpants
one because I I know I know I look yeah
see it there you go I I'm a sweatpant
lover and I I kind of am like of the
thought that if you're gonna be together
then you're going to see me in
sweatpants a lot I I got stuff to do I
got more important things on my mind
than my pants so apart from that I think
it's really important I love the date
night wand because I think especially if
it's two busy people and it's I've
totally fallen into that trap before
where I'm like well it's just busy let's
just order and let's just like or let's
just eat in the bed and like go to bed
and like whatever whatever oh my God I'm
like a slob I'm like a bed liver I'm
like just to eat the eat in bed go to
bed like we have to get up in the
morning and I've fallen into that trap
before and it's and it's nice to have
sex too you're right there it's just
like a One-Stop shop yeah very nice I
still love and think about all the time
that George Costanza can I eat a
sandwich and have sex at the same time
yeah exactly which really tries it seems
like he kind of accomplishes yeah yeah
almost I I have I haven't tried but I
but I would you know I would it wouldn't
be a sandwich for me it would be like
sushi so that might be like logistically
difficult but
I digress I eat prioritizing sex is
important so important you've got to
keep it you gotta carve out time for
that I co-sign on everything apart from
the sweatpants it's
you know what
I know I think I think you know the
athleisure wear is too ubiquitous for
that one you know it's too on Trend I
feel like that it worked in a bowler hat
era I also like to be in sweatpants so
that I can like surprise and Delight
when I do put on pants otherwise it's
more one note you know yeah I don't you
never know what you're gonna get with me
and my Amaya sweatpant Goblin or am I
like going to a red carpet event you
just spin the dice like I know and it's
nice to have that range I'm really just
showing my range I also had two kids and
I don't think there's anything more
uncomfortable on planet Earth than jeans
I don't know why but like if I was to
wear a medieval chastity belt I'm
convinced it'd be Cozier than a pair of
Levi's jeans are an absolute War crime I
don't wear them anymore I don't
associate with them they're not made for
people with hips I'm sorry it's it's
literally an industrial material that we
have made a Cornerstone of American
fashion why why I'm sorry what and
they're so cute I love the look of denim
I I see girls in jeans men in jeans I
look more like a man and jeans that's
also where I'm so I don't want to look
like jeans you know how like girls have
that cute like indented flat front yeah
and guys have the Bulge I have the ball
I have the Bulge too yeah I I listen I
have a very long torso they're just not
meant for for my body type and I don't
like especially the no stretch it's too
painful okay well that makes me feel
better because I used to wear nothing
but jeans and now it's like if I
literally try to stuff myself into a
pair just trust me I'm not comfortable I
may look cuter but I'm miserable
um you asked and now we're answering in
our first podcast edition of ask a desk
pert like it's like expert with a desk
yeah so it's like I have a list so same
sister okay good thank God no
they cancel we our lists cancel each
other out so actually we don't have one
on this spot all right so it's like
desks no because it's s's for me too so
this is
well and it's
d-e-s-k-p-e-r-t so desperate
dusk spurt see thank you I'm like I'm
convinced we should just come up with a
new name for this because I can't say it
you like hearing me be a fool all right
tanks and I will do our best to give you
all some advice our first question comes
from at Yeti climb if unsuccessful on a
dating app what are your suggestions of
other ways to meet people I love a setup
I love a setup and I think that people
think that it's cringe or embarrassing
to ask to be set up and I I think that
your friends are the greatest untapped
resource and maybe not like your best
friends because you know they would have
thought of it already I'm talking about
the friends you see once a month or
maybe even your favorite colleague at
work just ask them it's people love to
be asked for little favors it makes them
actually like you more it's been proven
ask your friend and say hey I'm trying
to put myself out there more do you have
anyone to set me up with doesn't matter
if they're not the love of my life just
someone fun to get a drink with take the
pressure off I'm telling you know it's a
great way to do it and ask like 10
people people need to put effort into
dating like it's a numbers game you have
to ask like 10 people you'll go on two
dates one of them will be good oh my God
I love this the last time someone
suggested that they introduced me to
someone it was they hooked me up
um like via text with uh someone they
knew he was a crew rower which I thought
like a teacher yeah like he wasn't like
he he was he was the teacher okay
um he wasn't like some 20 something year
old
um and um I did I texted with him and I
was like ooh cool crew that's
interesting but I said like when are you
gonna be in town and then it just like
it just Fizzles yeah yeah so I think
that you have to make the plan right
away like it's nice to get to know
someone a little bit but I'm like I need
to get in front of you smell your
pheromone yeah like hear your laugh you
know because that's all the chemistry
thing I'm gonna double down on what you
said okay so I wanna put your comment
front and center which is reach out to
your friends and ask to be set up ask at
least 10 people like really go for it
put yourself out there people love to be
needed and they love to sort of rise to
the occasion yeah it's inspiring it's
not a burden no it's nice I love setting
people up I have a marriage under my
belt that I set up I have a couple of
relationships that I've set up I love it
and people love love like what could be
better than you know I think it's
exciting and it's fun so and then I will
back that up because the one time it did
happen to me texting is the biggest
blocker it is it is just yeah a Road to
Nowhere most of the time not all the
time but I think the majority is please
don't get caught in a texting flight
pattern no pen pal you may never land
that plane no pen pals thank you all
right question number two is from at
ydoc James
question how do you handle an ax that
has the same friend group
um that's tricky that's tricky that's
why I like to date outside of my friend
group because I'd like a nice clean
break
um I think that you have to
be respectful and kind of set
expectations when the breakup happens
like all you can really do is be kind
and respectful is it going to be a
little awkward yeah and I think
accepting that is the first step and
then it's just about you know really
being kind to that person I think I'm
very into like the amicable breakup and
I'm not saying you have to be best
friends with them and sit next to them
at the group dinner but be kind smile
ask them how they are like this is
someone who you spend time with you are
in a relationship with and and if you
set that tone they will follow suit
because they're gonna look like
if they are rude to you or passive
aggressive in front of the rest of your
friends smile
be nice move move it along tanks I love
it take the high road yeah and you do
set the tone yeah and I really empathize
with people out there who feel like I
just lost my love and my support group
all feelings are valid all behaviors are
not you should feel that way it's too
much it's like I've lost my lover and my
friend your friends on one yeah couldn't
feel more isolated alone and like deeper
into heartbreak I cannot empathize more
yeah I still go with your notion of
please act kind and respectful and it's
not probably the best idea to play dirty
go below the Bell behave nasty
Poison the Well yeah like your friends
like that's another really good tip
point don't Poison the Well don't talk
bad about your ex to the friends because
it's only going to reflect badly on you
and it's only going to make the breakup
and the animosity worse just just don't
don't complain don't just and by the way
just picture this that everyone is
literally like oh my God that person's
so amazing like they're just behaving so
well and we're all over here and we miss
them and we wish they were back and we
wish we weren't caught up in this thing
and oh my God rather than thank God
they're gone they're a toxic person yeah
like play the part you will win the game
exactly
next question from Gracie Napier do you
agree that women can literally smell
when their partner is cheating on them I
I do believe in a woman's intuition I do
too I really really understand I I
really really do think that it's kind of
a sixth sense I co-signed to say a tank
system yeah it's it's it's just a weird
tingle it's just a weird tingle and I've
had it it's brutal that when you get the
tingle it's impossible to ignore and
this is not a good thing it's not a good
tingle it's the opposite um but yeah I
do I I just I I don't even know if I
have a a coherent intelligent answer
other than I think it's that witchiness
inside all of us that we just are like
something's a little off
I almost every time I suspected it was
the case yeah I found the evidence and I
don't suggest that people go deep diving
and like invade people's privacy
um however
you're probably not likely to get a
totally honest answer so I'm not sure
like asking is going to help you find
your evidence because the person could
easily just lie just not tell you the
truth and and avoid the confrontation
and just take the lazy Road out and just
not deal with it yeah um because that's
probably what they're doing in the first
place because my suggestion to anyone
who wants to philander is just be free
and not committed to someone else so you
are free and then you're not for
philandering exactly but I swear it's
crazy it's there is and you called it
intuition it's like a spidey sense yeah
a bad tingle
a suspicion you know what people don't
acknowledge the gut enough it's the head
poetry
gut instinct is where it's at and if
your gut is telling you something is off
more times than not it is there's
something off yeah I love that phrase uh
gut feelings or guardian angels and I
love that and I always think about that
so listen to your gut it's it's so true
and and honestly our gut and our mind
are super connected and I don't know I'm
just it there were one system in your
gut those pangs that you get just pay
attention to them because sometimes it's
true but don't go through anyone's phone
yeah it'll come out it'll come out just
be if you have the spidey sense just
keep a watch it always comes out it does
and please don't go through people's
stuff I don't think that's you know a
good behavior or anything we're
suggesting and I think if it just
continues on and you never feel settled
and you always feel like something is
awry and nefarious things are at play
maybe it's not the right relationship
period exactly because yes that's such a
good point if you constantly feel on
edge even if you don't find something or
even if it it ends up not being true
Drew is right then that's not your
person because you should feel calm and
safe and secure with the person that
you're with wouldn't that be nice
um okay our final question is from
Catherine Burnell and she wants to know
how to navigate making more money than
her boyfriend that's a really
interesting one I know it's tough it's
tough It's blunt and I appreciate it I
appreciate that listen we are out here
girl bossing very hard these days and
I'm so proud of everyone who is I think
I think you know don't don't dim your
light don't be embarrassed don't
um try to shine any less brightly I
think it's something to be proud of how
much you know if you're successful
um
it's tough because I you know I don't
want to make a sweeping generalization
but I'm going to the male ego can be a
little bit fragile when it comes to that
stuff it can but it doesn't mean you
have to change your behavior and I think
if it's the right relationship your
partner should be super supportive of
your success and and think that it's
badass that you are our girl bossing so
hard
um so yeah I guess my advice would be
don't dim your light and just be mindful
of it I think that's great advice do not
dim your light I think that's very
empowering and very directional I'm
gonna Loop us right back to the
beginning of the conversation and in
storytelling what they consider a payoff
I'm gonna be able to have one right now
also don't get lost in your ego why are
you competing I love that's right amen
so don't let them dim your light be
proud of who you are do not compete with
someone no and don't get into your ego
and as you also said find somebody who
at your highest and lowest is there to
support you and cheer you on regardless
I love that it doesn't matter as long as
they're supporting you and you're
supporting them and and you're happy
that's what matters and and the rest is
just extra
thanks damn it I just love hanging out
with you thank you so much thanks for
having me whether we're on the show
together or I'm calling into yours I
just enjoy your wisdoms and your
calmness and your attitudes and your
high roadness and your fun and we're all
in for it and I just am so excited to do
this now because this is a new field for
me
um I'm feeling more comfortable on the
show so I thought you know what why not
start a new challenge and scare myself
yet again and try and get into the
podcast world and getting to do it with
you is just so fun and exciting thank
you thank you for having me you are a
natural and so inspiring you are just
firing on all cylinders right now and
it's very very cool and inspiring to see
so thank you for having me I wish you
could see my face I look wide-eyed and
shocked and grateful at the at the
encouragement
and um to everybody out there thank you
so much for listening follow the Drew's
News podcast wherever you get your
podcast and you know if you like you can
tell someone you know or shout it from a
rooftop you know or hey you could like
be at a drive-through and be like you
know what I'll take some fries and also
by the way have you heard the Drew's
News podcast I mean you could be like
taking care of your neighbor's pet and
and tell that cat like hey if you're
bored because you're stuck at home all
day like there's a podcast you could put
on and you know I'm just saying you know
I mean tinks is on the podcast and so
for me I think that's worth anybody
getting to listen to her and her wisdoms
and be sure to watch oh God here's my
name the Drew Barrymore show every
weekday and uh you can go to the Drew
Barrymore show.com or you know what just
go to the YouTube channel go to the like
Instagram go to the tick tock let's face
it who's going to our website anymore no
one you can find us on your local time
and channel one thing I do suggest you
can go to our website and type in your
zip code and then you can find where our
show is on for you and other than that
ignore it okay thank you everybody as
always we make the show for you so take
it with you thanks tinks
[Music]